everything's racist even anti-racism so
you know
i
i know it's complicated but there was
racism right
and then there was not
being a racist so you're either a racist
or you're not a racist but then in the
last few years that's not good enough
it's not good enough to be not a racist
we hear from ibram kindy and robin
d'angelo and all the other
hustlers so now you've got to be an
anti-racist
but then what i just learned yesterday
this one's going to shock you
is that anti-racism
is racist
trish farley she's a white woman who uh
i met when i joined when i started
working with the people's institute of
survival beyond and she calls herself
and i'm borrowing this from her but it
just she calls herself a racist
anti-racist
and i really
love that term as a white woman because
again you know this and you know for
those people familiar with the people's
institute the definition of racism as
defined by them is race prejudice
plus power equals racism so
in that definition i i am as a white
person a racist it doesn't mean that i'm
purposely that my beliefs are purposeful
and i'm doing things on purpose and yet
i can't be a white person living in this
society and not be benefiting from
racism so
i i kind of so i love that term of you
know i'm a racist anti-racist i'm a
racist anti-racist so what she's saying
she actually didn't define it
precisely even according to her own
kooky definition
she is saying
that
you need power it's not just enough to
have racial prejudice black people might
hate white people but but we're defining
black people as not having any power
here so
they can't be racist
you need you need power in order to be
racist so the only racists according to
this definition because white people are
defined as the only ones with power the
only racists or white people but she
goes further she doesn't just say that
all racists are white people she's
saying all white people are racists
that even she as an anti-racist
is a racist because white people can
never overcome their racism even if they
become very conscious of it even if they
become
activists on anti-racism they still
can't overcome their
racism which
implies to me that maybe we should just
give it up then who cares if it's not
possible if all white people are racist
and they cannot ameliorate this in any
way they can't overcome it then all
right i guess that's just how we are
okay
where's the nearest hood because i'm
told
by reliable sources that i there's no
way to overcome it so why would i try if
you're telling me it's a futile attempt
but but more there's something even
stupider about what she's saying
which is that it violates
aristotle's law of non-contradiction you
can't to too contradictory things cannot
simultaneously be true to mutually
contradictory things can't at the same
time be true i cannot at the same time
be a racist and an anti-racist it's not
possible
i i can't do it
just like
a
this this leftist year's tumbler cannot
at the same time be black and white
right to you
to keep with our
color and hue analogy it can't at the
same time be black and white
because those are mutually exclusive
things they would contradict one another
it's not gray right it's not it's
it's i either one or the other something
cannot at the same time be true and
false
it has to be
one or the other
but they don't know that they don't know
that so it's all racist
it's all anti-racist it's all
it's lunacy it's lunacy and this is why
by the way when you hear about critical
race theory or you hear about some of
this activism in the schools
one thing that keeps cropping up in all
the pamphlets and all the lessons and
all the powerpoints is this idea that
there is no objective truth
you remember that in in one of the
anti-racist pamphlets from the
smithsonian they said that objective
truth
reality reason
uh these are white supremacist dog
whistles
why it's not just a funny quirk of of
this activism
this activism this ideology
must undermine objective truth it must
undermine logic it must undermine reason
because if you have logic if you have
reason if there is objective truth
then the ideology doesn't make sense
if there is such a thing as logic then
you cannot be an anti-racist racist a
racist anti-racist
ist-ist anti-anti this that and the
other thing
you beautiful person i'm so glad that
you enjoyed that video if you wouldn't
mind leaving me a comment that would
make me feel very nice you know just
saying hey michael my sweater thank you
i like but also what i need you to do
is go to wherever you get your audio
podcasts
and subscribe to the michael knowles
show it could be apple podcast stitch
your spotify google play wherever head
on over there right now
take out the old phone
here i got i got mine
got a lot of people spying on me no
doubt go type in okay podcasts go type
in the
michael knowles show
subscribe so easy you can leave a
five-star review if you want we
appreciate it helps us get around a
little big tech censorship we'll see you
next time
[Music]
[Music]